[Musique]
il y a deux choses importantes pour bien
travailler dans le cadre de ses études
il ya les méthodologies c'est à dire
comment savoir apprendre ça le plus
souvent on peut trouver des des vidéos
intéressantes sur le net ou demander à
ses professeurs très important la
méthodologie parce que sinon on perd un
temps un temps fou on travaille pour
rien on dépense son énergie pour rien
mais il y a quelque chose que les
professeurs en revanche ne pourront
jamais vos données
c'est la concentration et la
concentration c'est vraiment primordial
il ya on va dire trois ingrédients de la
concentration est roi c'est la confiance
dire qu'il faut sentir qu'on est capable
d'apprendre qu'on est capable de
travailler croire en sa capacité de
réussite parce que sinon si vous êtes en
train de douter bien servir est vrai pas
bien évidemment ça parasites vos pensez
vous être efficace il faut le calme
encore une fois le stress c'est un
parasite il faut s'en débarrasser
et puis il faut ce troisième ses pieds
évidemment la concentration capacité de
concentration et parle de deux focus
également donc en gros c'est une
neutralité dans la tête
la confiance une neutralité dans le
corps et
une concentration c'est à dire oublier
tout ce qui est à l'extérieur
elie plein soit vous permettre de faire
ça préfacier revanche c'est important de
répéter la séance vous l'a fait à chaque
fois que vous devez révisé vous allez
bien sûr perdre un tout petit peu de
temps mais ce sera une sorte
d'investissement
c'est à l'école de temps que vous allez
perdre séance d'hypnose
vous allez le gagner en efficacité en
productivité
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez trouver
des enregistrements d'hypnose des mp3
des informations sur ce sujet des
articles sur le site 6-2 point fr
d'autres vidéos très nombreux sur
l'hypnose la relaxation les techniques
pour bien travailler qu'on se concentre
et mémoriser terrain sur ma chaîne
youtube
slash haye coaching et puis surtout il
ya toutes ces belles vidéos qu'on est en
train de tourner avec le figaro toutes
ces séances d'hypnose très pratique qui
vont pouvoir nous servir on sur le jour
et celle là on fait partie
alors vous êtes prêts
première chose avant de travailler c'est
de dégager son espace de travail
c'est vital il faut pas qu'il y ait des
perturbations comme ça il faut qu'il y
ait le moins de choses possibles sur
votre espace de travail simplement un
livre de quoi écrire un ordinateur
éventuellement et c'est tout on évite
les distractions et puis ensuite
ensuite prenez le temps un petit peu de
vous étirer sert de votre tête comme ça
pour détendre le coût est un peu
travaillé les épaules
étirez vous au niveau des bras tout ça
pour être dans déjà dans une attitude où
vous pourrez travailler sont en sus il
faut pas que le corps vous empêchent de
bien travailler
une fois que c'est fait il suffit de
vous laisser porter c'est là que la
séance d'hypnose va commencer je vous
inviter à fixer un point ce évidemment
ça peut être par exemple images de cette
vidéo
ça peut être un autre point si vous
préférez commencer à le regarder avec un
regard tout
vous savez cette impression qu'on a
quand on sent qu'on est en train de bien
travailler quand on se sent vraiment
absorber eh bien naturellement on a
tendance à un tout petit peu plisser les
yeux et à 30 ans une focalisation de
cage je vous invitais aussi à prendre 3
respiration profonde
et ce sera comme ça de rituel à chaque
fois que vous commencerez à travailler
alors je vous invite simplement à
écouter ma voix
et puis aussi en même temps à prêter
attention au bruit autour de vous il ya
toujours des diversions des bruits
autour de soi ne faut surtout pas se
défendre
il vaut mieux les accepter comme ça ils
vont faire partie de votre environnement
vous permettre ensuite de ne plus être
dissipé alors simplement écouter les
bruits autour de la voix qui va se
préciser pour vous guider
mais aussi le bruit d'autres personnes
peut être qu'ils travaillent le bruit
d'une sorte d'agitation sourde autour de
vous et puis simplement vous prêter une
attention douce à tout cela ma voix elle
va se préciser en vo de plus en plus
puis lycée c'est vous bien vous vous
installez points deux fois les cvo vos
épaules retomber un peu mais celle ci
les muscles du visage
retombée comme si vous ne mettiez plus
d'énergie dans le visage
comme si vous retrouvez une sorte de
position neutre c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle au théâtre cette position cette
posture neutre
cette potion ne fait pas d'efforts on
laisse donc les bras tomber les épaules
tombe et laisse le visage tomber et
entre les trois respiration du début et
la voix qui vous accompagnent déjà se
met en place un processus au fur et à
mesure que votre attention se pose de
plus en plus sur votre respiration douce
lente calme et concentré vous entrez de
plus en plus en transe c'était à tout
est calme et penser qu'ils existent
dépenses est consciente
il ya forcément au départ cette idée
toute simple est ce que ça va marcher
est ce que je serai plus concentré
qu'est ce que ça va donner ses pensées
qui disparaîtront heureusement de deux
fois en fois mesure que vous pourrez
ressentir observer tout simplement
presque d'une manière scientifique
observez vos progrès au fur et à mesure
car vous allez apprendre à vous
concentrer et observer comme la
concentration finalement est quelque
chose de plutôt passif
plus on est détendu long et calmes plus
on peut absorber les informations
il faut être capable de se détend et
simplement laissé son attention se
porter sur un jour en ce moment à voir
votre respiration également plus lente
qu'à 6 et brille autour de vous ont
commencé à rentrer dans une sorte de
bulle
vous pouvez sentir sentir comme une
sorte de lourdeur dans les bras les
jambes encore une sorte de pesanteurs
qui tout à l'heure vous fera pencher la
tête des branches et toutes vos pensées
vers ce travail vous verrez comme les
choses deviendront plus facile
simplement parce que vous n'y mettrai
plus d'efforts davantage entrants et
j'aime bien cette succession d'image
je répète souvent de séance en séance
imaginez votre corps assis sur cette
chaise la chaise en craie sur le sol sol
ancré sur
des fondations de cet endroit et se
mettre un peu à rêver le temps ensuite
de se refocaliser la terre ancré dans le
système solaire système solaire ont créé
dans la galaxie la galaxie ont créé dans
l'univers l'univers ancré dans le temps
le temps sourit n'en ont créé un vent
tandis que nous on crée de plus en plus
dans cette concentration dans cette
focalisation intérieur l'hypnose il est
un spectacle qui a agréé
lorsqu'on voit en sortant sa tête d'une
copie toutes les autres têtes penchées à
travailler quand on est dans une salle
d'examen ça quelque chose de
l'hypnotique de voir toutes ces
personnes concentrées sur la même chose
de ressentir finalement de silence
ce silence même alors que viennent à vos
oreilles les bruits des bruits occupé
peut-être des cliquetis des claviers
d'ordinateurs des bruits d'écriture
peut-être d'autres bruits des voix
sourde et à quelque chose d'hypnotique
donc à sentir toute cette salle
complètement ancré dans une sorte de
recueillement ça donne envie de
d'étudier avec eux je te dis with me est
un type de vidéos qu'on voit sur le net
on peut observer quelques uns en train
de travailler et ça quelque chose de
deux doucement contagieux
on commence à ressentir le plaisir de te
sentir qu'on s'attelle à la tâche qu'on
est de plus en plus concentré de plus en
plus en transe vous centrez de plus en
plus entendre au fur et à mesure que ma
voix vous accompagne lui permettez se
mettre dans un recueillement qui plus
tard lui servira de base à une
concentration meilleur et donc et une
mémorisation meilleur et pendant que vos
pensées
conscient d'un côté les sensations les
ressentis inconscient de l'autre lors
qu'une partie de vous est assez stable à
6 une autre partie elle s'envole art
avec moi une partie beaucoup plus
réceptives et plus cette partie
consciente se fatiguent et abandonne s
party l'observation et les pensées et
plus ma voix prendre place sans vous et
vous permet de vous concentrer davantage
c'est pour ça qu'on apprendre des
langues étrangères avec les doses à
prendre des coups
parce que c'est un état où un calme ne
compte que la voie est donc aussi penser
ces phases peuple est pensée consciente
pour laisser davantage de place à
l'inconscient et c'est très bien comme
ça je mentais à votre esprit inconscient
de vous faire imaginer une bulle autour
de vous une bulle qui englobera votre
surface de travail une bulle qui va vous
protéger et maintenir à la fois et le
calme et la concentration alors que
cette bulle se précise
vous êtes de plus en plus en transe plus
en plus calme plus en plus tranquille
c'est très bien
toujours plus en transe lorsque vous en
aurez besoin
il vous suffira de repenser et de
ressentir cette bulle à nouveau pour
refocaliser toute votre attention sur le
travail je vais demander à votre esprit
inconscient simplement vous faire vous
souvenir d'un moment où vous avez
particulièrement bien travaillé a pris
le sont c'était peut-être chez vous en
ils ont un livre tellement claire
tellement sein des choses autrefois
obscur s'éclaircissait au fur et à
mesure de la lecture c'est peut-être
lors d'un examen
vous sentiez bien vous étiez confiant et
que vous avez réussi peut-être que c'est
un autre moment ici votre inconscient
faire revivre cette sensation de
concentration la confiance qu'elle amène
cette impression de recevoir un peu
comme non boirait une fontaine lors du
savoir il a quelque chose de naturel et
quel que soit résultats scolaires vous
avez déjà bien appris
vous savez déjà bien travaillé et
surtout cette sensation à son repréciser
ans vous êtes intérieure s'étend la
bulle et vous revivez cette
concentration et pour chacun d'entre
nous
cette concentration est différente si il
y a en commun cette passivité réceptive
cette focalisation il y à aussi chaque
personne des sensations inconsciente
ça peut être un petit sentiment de joie
peut-être un petit sentiment de fierté
et dans un effort conscient je vais vous
demander de poser vos deux mains à plat
sur votre table sur votre surface de
travail et ce geste va s'ancrer avec
cette sensation de concentration que
vous ressentez ce qui fait que deux fois
en fois imposant simplement la paume des
mains sur le bureau prenons t3 profonde
respiration et en laissant la sensation
de cette bulle autour de vaud qui vous
protège la concentration va revenir même
si vous ne disposez pas de cet
enregistrement à ce moment là et
seulement une fois que vous aurez fait
c'est j'assume en une fois que vous
aurez capturer l'essence de votre
concentration
vous partirez
rien ne sert de courir il faut partir à
point tout le monde connaît la morale de
cette fable et c'est tellement voit
d'abord le calme est ensuite la
créativité l'intelligence qui s'exprime
dans votre travail d'abord se pose et
ensuite on laisse le mouvement de
l'esprit saint carné dans vos lectures
dans vos examens dans ses écrits je vous
invite ensuite à vous lancer directement
dans le travail sans s'arrêter sans
prendre une pause on réfléchit on se
calme et on agit et une fois qu'on agit
on ne pense plus on apprend on écrit on
reçoit route à vous êtes prêts à
travailler et apprend c'est maintenant
votre esprit votre travail qui vont
prendre la place de ma voix le meilleur
de vous même